وقد تظاهر مواطنون سودانيون امام حاميه
للجيش السوداني في ناحيه مروي في الولايه
الشماليه الليله الاربعاء للتضامن مع
القوات المسلحه وردد المتظاهرون هتافات
مسانده للجيش واظهر فيديو انتشر على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي قائدا لفرقه في الجيش
السوداني في المنطقه وهو يخاطب المواطنين
ويؤكد لهم ان الوضع تحت السيطره
للمزيد ينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل
الجزيره الطاهر المرضي اهلا بك معنا
نحاول متابعه تطورات المشهد المتسارعه وما
جاء في بيان الجيش وهل من ردود فعل عليه
من قبل قوات الدعم السريع حتى الان
نعم فعلا هنالك خطوات متسارعه في هذه
الاحداث هو ان البيان الذي اصدره الجيش
السوداني يؤكد ان الامور وصلت مرحله
التحشيد العسكري وانه كما ذكر بان يدقن
قوس الخطر لما بدا من قوات الدعم السريع
وقال انها انفتحت واعاده انتشارها في هذه
المناطق دون ادنى تنسيق من مع الجيش
السوداني في العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك في
الولايات وتحدث بانها محاولاتها لن تنقطع
في محاوله لنزف فتيل التوتر هذا يدل على
ان الخلافات التي كانت بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني كانت لها محاولات
فتيله التوتر والوصول الى
حد لوقف هذا التوتر وهذه المساله ولكن
يبدو ان كل المحاولات باعت بالفشل
وبالتالي وصلت الى هذا الحد الدعم السريع
اصدر بيان لان هذه
الانفتاحات وهذا وهذه اعاده الانتشار هي
تاتي وفق قانون الدعم السريع وان هنالك
تنسيق اصلا موجود وانا له وجود في كل
الولايات على كلنا ان هنالك هذين
البيانيين يوضحان ان هنالك خلاف في اداره
هذه الازمه او اداره مساله قوات الدعم
السريع والتحركات وكذلك في الجيش ولكن
الامور وصلت الى درجه التعشيد في مدينه
مروي بعد ان وصلت ارتال من قوات الدعم
السريع الى بالقرب من مطار مروي وكذلك
هنالك اليات وصلت من الجيش السوداني الى
هذه المدينه هذه يدل على ان الاوضاع بلغت
مبلغا
شديد الخطوره وهنالك ايضا
حديث من ناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
بان القوات المسلحه ستحافظ على امن
السودان وهي لا تريد اي نوع من الصدام لان
الحرب ستقضي على الاخضر واليابس وبالتالي
هي تحاول بكل سبل ان تجنب البلاد اي نوع
من الصدام في الظروف يمر فيها السودان
ظروف دقيقه وخطر للغايه وبالتالي اكد ايضا
من الناحيه السياسيه انه ملتزم بالاتفاق
الاطاري الذي يتعثر حتى الان باسباب
مختلفه وخاصه من بين هذه الاسباب هو مساله
دمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش بعد ان
انتهت هذه الورشه التي كانت تتحدث عن
عمليه دمج قوات الدعم السريع والاصلاح
الامني والعسكري الى ليان فنيه ويبدو ان
هذه اللجان الفنيه ايضا وصلت الى طريق
مسدود وان الامور يعني خارج السيطره ولكن
الجيش يؤكد التزام بالاتفاق يحذر القوه
السياسيه من اي محاوله للمزايده بيئه
مواقف القوات المسلحه
والابتعاد في هذا الموضوع اذا نحن نراقب
هذا الوضع عن كثب بما يدور من تحليل الوقت
مازال مبكر بالنسبه للردود الفعل سواء كان
من الدعم السريع بردا على بيان الجيش او
من القوه السياسيه والحراك بصفه عامه
وبالنسبه حتى بالنسبه السودانيين هم يرون
ان هذه التطورات تطورات خطيره وتهدد امن
واستقرار البلاد وبالتالي هم يرون ان
التعقل في مثل هذه الظروف ومحاوله نزع
فتيل التوتر عن طريق والحوار وكذا يجفف
البلاد مزيد من الانقسامات وهذا ما نتابعه
في الساعات القادمه نعم والمهله التي اعلن
عنها 24 ساعه سنبقى بطبيعه الحال في
المتابعه لاي تطورات الطائر المرضي من
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك